the united states of fear that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now the press and the party that they
represent they want you to be afraid and
i'm talking very afraid
coveted subveriance they're here they're
super duper contagious so consider
changing your travel plans if you're
thinking of attending big events
i can tell you with more variants
specifically sub-variants of omicron
circulating more of us are vulnerable
for reinfection we are looking at the
fall and winter we're preparing for
variety of scenarios i think a
potentially a difficult one if we get a
resurgence of the infection
very very scary and by the way if you
happen to be african-american they want
you to be afraid of police because
they'll tell you you're going to be
indiscriminately killed for no reason
other than the color of your skin
because it's an epidemic out there of
police involved shootings
what exactly will it take to stop this
level of execution-style killing of
black men and black women at the hands
of law enforcement this needs to be at
the top of the list for the attorney
general to address white supremacy and
those organizations
in law enforcement and outside of law
enforcement around the country that are
targeting black and brown people
all right well that's an ugly lie the
truth is if suspects simply do not
resist arrest they don't run away they
don't turn and look like they're firing
a gun at police the chance of being
injured let alone shot by a police
officer is infinitesimally small
but still they want you afraid and not
trusting of anyone in uniform ever
and of course they want you afraid of
climate change hello you know why have
children when the planet's going to burn
up and flood
you need to rethink your carbon use kids
climate is a code red now we have to
take action we have so little time we
need to be sort of throw everything at
it that we can
they want you so panicked that you'll in
the end be totally fine with traveling
less
paying six dollars seven dollars ten
dollars a gallon for gas for the good of
the planet and by the way then you can
blame gas station owners for price
gouging
over the weekend president biden tweeted
well a comment to mostly mom and pop
shots who are just trying to get by now
saying this is a time of global war and
global peril bring down the price you're
charging at the pump to reflect the cost
you're paying for the product and do it
now
now if this is biden's answer to high
energy prices
the man is totally out of gas now they
also want you afraid of speaking your
mind because if you do you could lose
your job lose your promotion lose your
board seat lose your spot in college
even a position in the u.s military
sheller posted a video on social media
criticizing military leaders for
mistakes made during the withdrawal from
afghanistan and demanding accountability
sheller was relieved of duty today's
decision to stop publishing six dr seuss
books comes after they've been
criticized for spreading racist images
as a small but growing revolt of artists
scrubbed their music from the streaming
platform specifically took issue with
the joe rogan experience the university
of virginia says it recently disenrolled
49 students who signed up for classes
but then failed to provide a vaccine
card
and after the horror that was visited
upon highland park yesterday
they even want you afraid of attending
patriotic celebrations
a fourth of july tradition is just too
dangerous going forward no place is safe
in this showing that there are no
holidays for mass shootings in america
we have to do something
now and
no community is safe no community is
safe in a wealthy suburb of the of
chicago the maybe the quintessential
american city
in the heartland on the fourth of july
at a parade if you're not safe there
where are you safe
okay
the the shooting happens every weekend
by the way in chicago st louis baltimore
they don't have that you know freaked
out view on their faces but because it's
highland park oh yes but using this evil
act to try to wipe out patriotic
traditions which you know is ultimately
what's going on here is a new low even
for the left
now of course they want you also afraid
to own a gun or to apply for a concealed
carry permit because they're going to
make sure that your name and your
address leaks accidentally as they did
in california
but instead of selling fear and division
wouldn't it be nice if we all began to
focus on solutions don't people want
solutions i sense they do
now on the mass shooting in illinois
indications are that robert cremo was a
regular pot user now one look at him and
to the untrained eye he looks like a
complete psychotic you ever seen anyone
looking like him and what can regular
pot use trigger in young men in
particular
psychosis and other violent personality
changes not everyone but a significant
percentage now police say that in 2019
they were called to the shooter's home
twice
the first was in april 2019 after a
reported suicide attempt by cremo and
the second was in september 2019 after
receiving a call from a family member
who said he was threatening to kill
everyone police removed 16 knives a
dagger and a sword from the house but
they say
there was no probable cause to make an
arrest at the time
just kind of run-of-the-mill behavior i
guess
and much of his online presence points
to simmering psycho psychosis because
under the stage name awake the rapper he
posted a disturbing music video and this
was back in 2021 that featured drawings
of a stick figure wearing a tactical
gear carrying an attack with a rifle
newspaper clipping about lee harvey
oswald who assassinated jfk totally off
the wall stuff now we know he planned
the attack for weeks and even disguised
himself as a woman to get away again
all the signs were there
but in a positive development over the
past few weeks the media seemed to be
recognizing the danger of sustained high
thc content uh in young people regular
use among young people now it only took
them i don't know four years to catch up
to what the science and er nurses and
doctors were screaming about in places
like colorado and california they saw it
with their own eyes
so the new york times writes one
rigorous study found that the risk of
having psychotic disorder was five times
higher among daily high potency cannabis
users in europe and brazil than those
who had never used it and dr sharon levy
from boston's children's hospital told
the paper the younger you are the more
vulnerable your brain is to developing
these problems
but for some reason
you're thinking about all these horrific
acts of evil that have been perpetrated
in the american public
we still weeks later
don't have a toxicology report from the
uvalde mass shooter
despite early reports that he was a
regular weed user
why the delay
congress rushed in to pass this gun
control bill in the aftermath of the
just heinous shooting but where's the
demand for answers on other key aspects
of the case
no curiosity there whatsoever
let me tell you this
the marijuana industry is making
billions on the lie that weed is fine no
big deal and even for
young people healthy people it's great
it could be healthy for you in fact
no one is arguing by the way nor have i
that most people who use high thc
products end up as violent psychotics
that's ridiculous
but
there is mounting scientific evidence of
a connection between the increase in
violent behavior among young people and
regular sustained cannabis use
so if the media wants to spend time
scaring people focus on scaring young
people away from what what would make
sense what would actually be helpful
scare them away from using this drug
as young people
but i'll tell you the pot industry is
extremely well funded
and it's even protected by some high
place republicans
remember former house speaker john
boehner saw a quick buck to be made and
joined an advisory board of a big pot
company after being against legalizing
pot
and democrats like new york city mayor
eric adams sees the extra tax revenue
from pot it's great for him it's
disgusting when you visit new york
so big weed uses its well-paid pot
pushing media allies and social media
influencers to trash anyone who
questions the mad rush to legalization
i can tell you this i don't give a rip
they trash me morning noon and night i
don't care because they're pushing pot
on our kids
we're pushing for answers and
accountability
these are the eyes of some of the mass
killers
who've reportedly been regular pot users
look at them
those in politics and in the media who
devote their time and energy
to fear mongering on fake issues
while covering up the truth about the
growing scourge of violent psychosis in
our young people
they have to be called out
they have to be defeated and then the
public has to be educated
and parents
this means you need to get into the game
this means you understanding that this
can happen to you to your family no
matter how wealthy you are how well
adjusted you are how mature and together
your children seem
it's time to call out the phonies and
call in the warriors for common sense
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else